so this is a Green Mile very green it's
very green it was just a thing to do on
the weekends now there's million dollars
tournaments there's 18 million dollar
tournaments that's something we never
saw years ago it was like Amazon was
books on the internet you know eBay was
like your collectibles your garage on
the Internet there's another wave the
internet going into the real world
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world now I started to believe
life seriously try to cover other topics
that you might be interested in beyond
just the typical content on my channel
so today we're gonna look at for edgy
businesses that would scare most people
to start enjoy
[Music]
business number one is the we business
but with being America's fastest-growing
industry comes growing pains marijuana
is still illegal on the federal level
which has led to conflicting state laws
restrictive regulations and endless
problems for cash-only marijuana
business owners and operators however
market projections of over 11 billion in
the next five years still have everyone
coming to town for the Green Rush we're
outside the cannabis cup in Denver it's
4/20 today it's basically like Christmas
for anyone who smokes marijuana the
cannabis cup looks like a giant pop
party but with legalization this
bleary-eyed consumer base represents a
huge financial opportunity unlike any
before with so much money to be made
4/20 isn't just for stoners anymore
meeting the political and legal
challenges of this emerging market is a
new kind of marijuana enthusiasts who's
getting into the game for a different
kind of green we just checked into the
marijuana investor summit which has a
completely different feel of the
cannabis cup and we're just gonna see
the big players that are investing in
this market today the summit joins the
growing list of conferences around the
country dedicated to networking and
investing in cannabis but most
importantly entrepreneurs are here to
learn how to become successful from the
few who got here first a clear example
of the shifting attitudes towards legal
marijuana can be seen in the demand for
industry experts to navigate new money
to success aside from the marijuana
plant itself consulting was one of the
most profitable sectors of the industry
last year travel avec is the CEO o for
American cannabis company a consulting
team that gives advice to businesses in
the legal space and helps connect them
with investors yeah it's cool to see the
the natural evolution of kind of what's
been progressing over the last you know
six eight 12 18 months of the space and
it kind of all culminates here at this
event for sure one of Trent's most
successful clients Andy Williams of
medicine man so we went to their largest
operation where he both grows and sells
marijuana so this is a Green Mile
Marygreen it's very green so these are
some of our mother plants this is what
we use to create new plants and so when
we look for genetics we look for good
big and fast those three things and when
we find it we grow a big plant and then
we clone it and we'll plant it and it
will be an exact genetic duplicate of
this plan let's go stand let me make a
little more go back in there a little
bit
all this green is reflecting from you we
talked about when we look at her Society
in North America there was prohibition
we understand what happened when
prohibition ended in the opportunities
that were presented in the liquor
industry so I see the industry is being
similar I'm not proposing that alcohol
is a good thing for society and they're
not proposing that marijuana is a good
thing for society but the reality is is
you can't stop them
obviously governments are looking at
this and saying well if we can regulate
it control the usage for our minors and
the almighty dollar in terms of Taxation
that's you know it's going to go there
well there are now a handful of
universities that teach classes about
weed Oaksterdam is the first
all-inclusive cannabis college in
america after prop 64 has passed what is
the legal landscape in California it's
not an accredited university but for
fifteen hundred and ninety five dollars
Oaksterdam offers a 14 week semester
where students take business law
politics and history classes just like
they would at a regular college but it's
all focused around cannabis and better
that it has this color but what's the
downside of making it blue how did you
end up being the chancellor of a weed
College in my former life I was a
manager and entrepreneur and a corporate
trainer and so I recognized immediately
that there needed to be some type of
training for the cannabis industry
especially for patients and also for
doctors quite frankly and it just didn't
exist how is this whole thing legal
because we teach in California we're
able to do hands-on and we're the only
hands-on lab in the world where you can
do what you did downstairs
the differences between say California
and New York or when we go to Las Vegas
is whether or not we can be hands-on
with the students so oftentimes we do
things like video when we go out of town
or we'll use alternative plants like
lavender or rosemary business number two
is eSports many people would call
competitive gaming or eSports a
subculture but is it really when it
packs this stadium for two days 15,000
people all here to watch their favorite
players compete in the North American
finals of League of Legends currently
the most rain in the world being a
professional gamer I never thought that
I could make a career out of doing
something that I love and that I'm so
passionate about which is video games it
was just a thing to do on the weekends
now there's million-dollars tournaments
there's 18 million dollar tournaments
that's something we never saw years ago
I can't tell you how many calls I
received I mean north of 50 phone calls
from pretty significant executives
saying okay tell me what you're doing
explain to me again what it is and most
importantly who do I call to try to get
engaged eSports are starting to look
more and more like regular sports last
year the Philadelphia 76ers became the
first North American team on the scene
they bought the uk-based Team Dignitas
this is an organization that is not done
growing so I think it fits really nicely
in a portfolio it's a very very young
demo and the space is exploding owners
of other major sports franchises are
investing in eSports and creating teams
of their own we want pros to be able to
have long successful careers and we felt
that bringing some stability would allow
that to happen we want teams and
sponsors to be able to invest for the
long-term if they want to build a
practice facility or invest in
infrastructure knowing that they can do
that with an investment horizon that
will have a negative payback on that
investment is important and we think all
of those things will help to make North
America more competitive because if you
look at the best leagues in the world
they're investing for the long-term
they've got the infrastructure they've
got the additional coaches and
nutritionists and facilities to really
make a run at it
eSports revenue is growing last year
revenues reach 490
three million dollars and is projected
to reach one-and-a-half billion dollars
by 2020 could eSports next big move be
to the Olympics the organizer for the
2024 Paris Summer Games is bringing the
case for the inclusion of eSports to the
IOC I think that the best sports in the
world tend to make it into the Olympics
and if we're lucky enough for that to
happen and for it to happen in the right
way we don't want it to be forced it
should be organic and not like a novelty
but something that is part of the
Olympic Games because it's a meaningful
sport for a lot of people around the
world which it is and we believe will
continue to be then I think you can make
a lot of sense business number three is
Airbnb some people described this is the
worst idea to ever worked a lot of
people build something cos they had a
great idea we built something a solved
problem and our problem was very simply
we couldn't afford to pay rent and I
think this is something that millions of
people can relate to they have space I
can't really afford to completely pay
for it they'd like some extra income
they want to be people that's what we
thought what is the way to book a home
anywhere around the world and that's
basically what's happened one of the
most common things people say when they
hear about the idea of everybody now and
I see people all over the world doing it
is why didn't I think of that it's such
a simple idea why didn't I think of that
you might not have thought of that it's
because when we thought about that years
ago then most common thing people said
is are you nuts we always thought you
know design isn't how something looks
designs how something works and we had
this really simple idea what if you
could go somewhere and feel like you
live there that simple idea was born of
necessity Chesky had quit his design job
and joined Gebbia in san francisco
between the two of them they couldn't
pay their first month's rent it turns
out that weekend there was this
internationals icon fence all the hotels
are sold out then we had this idea like
let's just create a bed-and-breakfast
for design conference we pulled the air
beds out of closet we inflated them and
we call it the air bed and breakfast a
light bulb went off but early skeptics
of their idea didn't believe people
would invite strangers into their homes
in 2008 without big investors Chesky and
Gebbia began covering their costs by
selling breakfast cereal and so
and they were totally broke and one
night were in a late late night in the
kitchen were like we're air bed and
breakfast air beds aren't selling very
well maybe we'll go in to breakfast
cereal and then we ended up selling
Barack Obama themed cereal to call that
Obama owes the breakfast of change we
also did John McCain themed cereal
captain McCain's and that was actually
how he funded the company in fact today
we say we're like serial entrepreneurs
their scrappiness caught the attention
of one of the company's first investors
right around the time the economy was
crashing we haven't made any money and
Paul Graham said that it's like an
investment nuclear winter and I'm
looking for people that won't die he
said in fact you guys were like
cockroaches you just won't die that's
when it started taking off then the idea
literally spread city by city block by
block it grew as a network what Airbnb
is a part of is a wave of the Internet
it was an Amazon was books on the
internet you know eBay was like your
collectibles your garage on the Internet
there's another wave the internet going
into the real world and so I think this
is the beginning so many people in 60
seconds can become entrepreneurs they
can start a business they can build a
reputation and Airbnb I think is just
the beginning now you see so many
companies in what people call the
sharing economy it's just like the first
chapter of it Airbnb recently launched a
new division called experiences
travelers can book a stay that comes
with a local experience like surfing
with adventure man in LA
finding Zen in San Francisco or learning
from a samurai artist in Tokyo I think
one of the things you and others have
found is that especially younger
customers are seeking these experiences
they don't want to accumulate things as
much as life experiences how did you tap
into that I think there was this shift
that happened where when I was a kid the
American dream was to have like a nice
house and two cars I think the right
social media changed it because suddenly
people started valuing experiences more
a new experience launching this month in
New York a partnership with an urban
farm called Harlem grown rent a room and
spend a day helping out have you seen
your research Brian that customers want
more of this kind of experience they
don't want to just see that whole tower
or like they don't want to see the
Statue of Liberty they want to meet
people like Tony and then you leave and
the memories you have are of people what
are the next 10 years look like for
Airbnb and I think where this is going
is not gonna be just a place to stay we
are going to design the end to end trip
for you
Travel is never really about when you go
it's about who you can become
and the memories you can make and I
really want us to be in the business of
creating these magical experiences not
just a place to stay this is number four
the last one before my special bonus
clips for you guys is the space industry
[Music]
you've made some money from the sale of
PayPal you decided to build a space
company why on earth would someone do
that got that question a lot that's true
we people - did you hear the joke about
the guy who made a small fortune in the
space industry you know obviously
started with a large one is the
punchline and so I tell people I was
trying to figure out the fastest way to
turn a large fortune into a small one
and they'd look at me like I was he
serious and say gee you are so it won't
open it was a close call main things
almost didn't work out we came very
close to failure but we managed to get
through that point in 2008 the the goal
of SpaceX is to try to advance rocket
technology and in particular to try to
crack a problem that I think is vital
for Humanity to become a spacefaring
civilization which is to have it rapidly
and fully reusable rocket would humanity
become a spacefaring civilization so
that was a dream of yours and a way from
a young age or like you've you dreamed
of Mars and Beyond I made I did build
rockets when I was a kid but I didn't
think I'd be involved in this it was
really more more from standpoint of what
are the things that need to happen in
order for the future to be an exciting
and inspiring one and I really I don't
think there's a fundamental difference
if you sort of look into the future
between a humanity that is at a
spacefaring civilization that's out
there exploring the Stars on multiple
planets and I think that's really
exciting and compared with one where we
have forever confined to earth until at
some eventual extinction event musk
decided that the only way to get an
affordable rocket was to build it
himself and he started SpaceX you ought
to be coming into the rocket business
you're not knowing anything about
rockets not having ever built anything I
mean I would have to be insane if I
thought the odds are in my favor
why even begin when something is
important enough you do it even though
it's not in your favor how much of your
personal fortune have you poured into
this
100 million dollars a hundred million
dollars into something that you did not
believe would work at the beginning yes
how did you get the expertise to be the
chief technology officer of a rocket
ship company well I do have a physics
background that's helpful as a
foundation and then I read a lot of
books and talked to a lot of a lot of
smart people you're self-taught
yeah well it's self-taught yes meaning I
didn't I don't have an aerospace degree
so how did you go about acquiring the
knowledge well I like said I had read a
lot of books talked a lot of people and
and have a great team
now I've got some special bonus clips
from Mark Cuban and other investors
talking about the eSports industry but
before that my question the day for you
is I want to know have you thought about
doing any of these businesses or is
there a 5 6 7 that you want to add to
the list of edgy businesses let me know
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clips
so we know you're a business guy you're
the owner of the Mavericks you're huge
on Shark Tank so I think that people
kind of want to know what's bringing you
here are you gonna be buying a team are
you investing into this you're just
gonna have to stay tuned I mean look one
thing I will say is I love Colin but
he's an idiot when it comes to eSports
right and we're of course talking about
my co-hosts on Fox Colin Cowherd who
calls a gamers nerds and I have to
disagree with them completely but what
do you have to say to guys like Colin
you just hate on the gamers look I'm a
noob you know I'm still getting into it
but I love it right it's like playing
five dimensional chest against the world
right it's like one of the smartest
games I've ever played you've got to
have dexterity you got to be quick this
is this is a real sport and people are
gonna figure it out really really quick
when and why did you get him get
involved in eSports and what was that
moment for you when you were like this
is what I want to do well I've been a
gamer for since I was a little kid and I
have to say that one of the big
crossroads for me is when I got involved
with twitch because streaming services
and gaming changed everything I started
seeing this link between potential fans
of mine or fans of mine that hard gamers
and realize that I want to get more
involved in gaming in in live streaming
in general beginning of this year I
started looking at at the team's I
started looking at how I can get
involved in any possibility I was trying
to game myself and I just realized I'm
just gamer even though these guys so the
better than I'd rather be an owner or
someone that could be part of you know
more so the marketing angle then you
know the operations obviously and it's a
lot of fun it's like you know for me I
always follow my passions and my passion
is leave me outside of music in
different for ace and now I'm in the bed
with everyone with all the gamers I tell
people I'm involved with these sports
and I'm sure we all hear it quite a bit
and it's their disbelief that people
actually pay to watch other people play
video games so what do you say to that
yeah for me I like to joke people
watching people play video games is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard which is
exactly what I said I see people shaking
exactly what I said myself seven years
ago until I saw and I was immediately
enchanted I was drawn into the world and
I thought you know I'm 32 years old I've
never experienced this feeling this is
what must be feel like an NFL fan seeing
an understanding football for the first
time but much like Jace I think the
common fed for all of us is we were
always gamers everyone's a gamer that's
the common thread so it's not a big leap
for us to seek out the stories of these
eSports athletes and I call them
athletes because they are in terms of
you know their journey through a season
up to a Finals you know we're doing
things to fight a lot of the
preconceived notions that gaming is bad
IMG Academy and for those that don't
know IMG's Academy is a school for
worldwide athletes like fantastic
athletes from across the globe so Venus
Serena Williams you know Cam Newton and
eSports is gonna be our ninth sport
there so we're going into the metrics
behind what's creates and makes these
people so specials and you know there's
injuries you know there's high player
turnover because they're just not as
fast anymore cognitive thinking and
things of that nature so we're looking
to change sort of the misconceptions
behind gaming and show a lot of the
positive as well if you have to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]